this week America chose our next
president a hat that's not serving
enough we just realized that while we
were immersed in the year-long army
crawl through diarrhea that was the 2016
campaign that really kind of feels like
all that Dan did Dufresne crawled
through to get out there was a bunch of
piping hot fire emoji content from the
world wide web that we didn't get to
cover like Vladimir Putin awarding
Steven Seagal Russian citizenship huh
and you didn't even know man you do this
daring heist to steal 50 grand worth of
bull semen very exciting I hope it was
already out of the bull when they tried
to steal it and this nightmare inducing
Lego man cosplay this looks like a
Batman villain happened it's just like
he fell into a vat at the Lego factory
and then became this guy so tonight
we're gonna revisit some of the comedy
gold we failed to mine during the
election because we're pretty
tired about talking about this King
collection like we totally missed this
one Ilana thank you one guy we totally I
know you guys want to keep talking about
it Elon Musk the handsome billionaire
inventor who's one accident a lab fire
away from being his own origin story
maybe he's that guy I don't know maybe
maybe this is Elon Musk
2025 we don't know but he said that we
are definitely living in a matrix style
simulation Telegraph quoted him as
saying maybe we should be hopeful this
is a simulation because otherwise we're
gonna create simulations
indistinguishable from reality or
civilizations ceases to exist so let me
ask you this if this is a simulated
reality why in the world would someone
virtually create this a blobfish why and
why does it look so sad it's like a
it's like a grumpy catfish or it looks
like the Ziggy comics but I think Elon
Musk could be onto something with matrix
theory so comedians what other movie
could we use to explain reality Jen
Kirkman
um Back to the Future because the Cubs
one of fascists is running things and
hoverboards look stupid all right boys
technically Back to the Future 2 G Lee
because it sucks and I make no money all
right boys Matt Braunger in two years
the hunger games right now Titanic all
right boys gentlemen it's been a
pleasure